des prêtres 20 ans de métier maître
artisan glacier depuis l'année dernière
pascal féval ouvre ses portes un 25
décembre pour la première fois un ancien
décorateur qui a tout quitté pour une
reconversion artisans glaciers
et à 20 ans on est encore en france
comme j'ai du mal
on était encore enfant il semble que
c'était quelque chose dans les 120
100 à 1000 francs 150 mille francs
lorsqu'on démarre une entreprise
il faut arriver avec 6 et à partir de ce
moment là une fois que vous avez fait
vos preuves
la boucle a bon goût suis un bon aussi
mais c'est pas l'un vers un maître
artisan glacier après plusieurs contenus
aujourd'hui il travaille jour férié ou
pas pour s'agrandir se réinventer il
s'agit de faire face aux dépenses à
venir six mois est prévue et refaire
refaire sa ligne de production tout cela
est prévu à avoir du personnel
tout cela est prévu aussi voilà puisque
là je suis passé du stade au
savoir-faire à le faire savoir
donc j'aurais bien aimé à une
transmission c'est notre dernière
dernière création c'est notre dernier
petit but mais est on a pris ce à dire
mont noir deux missionnaires de glace au
chocolat dionis posé sur une génoise
allumé nation d'alcool rhum vieux former
des jeunes pour assurer la relève
10 et ablassé bûche gâteau mousse
flammes pas de repos dans l'immédiat
reste à assurer les commandes jusqu'au
31 décembre